Nous venons de lire, j'ai écrit ces choses avec l'espérance d'aller bientôt te voir.
Mais afin que tu saches si j'étarde, comment il faut se conduire dans la maison des dieux,
qui est l'église de Dieu vivant, la colonne et l'appui de la vérité.
Et sans contredit, le mystère de la piété est grand.
C'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair, justifié par l'esprit, vu des anges,
prêché aux gentils, cru dans les mondes, élevé de la gloire.
Donc nous sommes devant un message qui a pour centre cette déclaration du verset 16,
qui nous présente un mystère incontestable qui a été révélé de manière incontestable,
qui doit être considéré comme incontestablement les plus grands de tous les mystères,
et un mystère qui concerne la piété.
Et la vérité nous est présentée de manière singulaire,
comme en étant composé de ces facettes que nous lisons au verset 16,
mais qui présente la première sentence comme celle qui est la plus importante,
la toute inclusive,
c'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair.
C'était la révélation de quelque chose qui serait pour toujours,
même si partiellement connu,
mais infiniment obscur,
c'est la contemplation des dieux.
La contemplation d'un dieu qui habite dans une lumière inaccessible,
un dieu qui est infiniment sang,
qui est infiniment transcendant.
Et même si ces empreintes sont perçues
de manière inexcusable pour tous,
ou par tous dans la création,
c'est un dieu qui reste
infiniment
au-delà de notre capacité de comprendre.
des manières qui connaître Dieu
ou contempler Dieu
de manière plus proche
devraient être
l'ambition la plus élevée de l'âme humaine,
les désirs les plus profonds,
les êtres humains.
Et le texte est en train de nous dire
que
ce dieu s'est manifesté,
il s'est révélé.
Et il s'est révélé
non seulement,
comme je vous ai dit,
par plusieurs manières indirectes
qu'on pourrait considérer,
mais particulièrement pour ceux
qui concernent l'être humain,
il s'est révélé
de la manière la plus accessible.
Voilà pourquoi il est considéré
comme la plus grande révélation
du plus grand des mystères.
Et c'est cette déclaration glorieuse,
c'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair.
Dieu s'est manifesté en forme humaine,
s'est fait accessible.
C'est ça le plus grand
de tous les mystères
qu'on aurait pu considérer.
Non seulement,
c'est mystérieux de chercher
à comprendre
de quelle manière
Dieu aurait pu devenir homme,
avec toutes nos limitations
de comprendre les mystères
de la double nature du Christ,
par exemple,
mais tout simplement,
le fait que Dieu
s'efface
si accessible
en forme humaine,
c'est la révélation
de la chose
la plus mystérieuse,
la plus glorieuse
qui pourrait se passer.
Donc voilà pourquoi
on a commencé
à méditer sur ces textes
dans notre culte de Noël,
nos séries sur Noël,
car ça nous parle clairement
de l'incarnation de Fusée,
de la manifestation en chair
des dieux lui-même.
OK ?
Sauf que dans les passages,
l'incarnation du Christ
ne doit jamais s'arrêter
dans ces glorieux miracles
de la gestation
de la Vierge Marie
par les Saint-Esprits
et la naissance du Christ
aux mangeoires.
Noël n'est qu'il y a quelque part
les débuts
de la grande
ou du grand accomplissement
de la plus grande œuvre de Dieu
vis-à-vis au salut des êtres humains.
Et voilà pourquoi
ce mystère révélé,
il est présenté
comme un ensemble.
C'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair,
a été justifié par l'Esprit,
vu des anges,
prêché aux gentils,
cru dans les mondes
et élevé dans la gloire.
Donc ici,
nous sommes devant
la contemplation
que les grands mystères révélés
ne peuvent qu'y concerner
la naissance du Christ,
l'incarnation du Fils des dieux,
mais l'ensemble de son œuvre
qui a un accomplissement
très évident
lorsqu'il est Christ,
est ressuscité
et élevé dans la gloire,
mais dont les implications
continuent pour toujours,
jusqu'au retour du Christ,
pour l'histoire de l'Église.
Et donc,
les implications
qui émanent
de la révélation
de ces mystères
qui a eu lieu
dans les temps
et dans l'espace,
l'incarnation,
vie,
mort,
résurrection
et glorification
de Christ,
mais cette élévation
du Christ dans la gloire
donne suite
à l'accomplissement
de l'objectif
de ces ministères,
à l'inauguration
du roi des dieux
sur terre
et Christ,
qui est la tête
élevée dans la gloire,
continue de manifester
la piété
à travers l'Église.
Voilà pourquoi
ces mystères
sont appelés
les grands mystères
de la piété,
la vie des dieux
entre les hommes.
Et pour renforcer
cette conviction,
pour plus que ces mystères
qui doivent être
notre déclaration,
notre confession,
il décrit aussi
la raison d'être
de l'Église.
Donc là,
Paul,
il va présenter
cette confession,
ces crédos,
cette déclaration
théologique,
pour décrire
ce qu'il appelle
être la vérité
sangulière.
Mais c'est une vérité
qui est
ou qui définit
l'identité
de l'Église
ou des croyants,
la mission
de l'Église
et des croyants,
et la joie
de l'Église
et des croyants.
Donc voilà pourquoi
il est appelé
mystère de la piété,
car ce que Paul
est en train de faire,
il est en train de donner
des coordonnées
à Timothée.
S'il tarde,
car ce sont des choses
si importantes
qu'il voulait parler
à vive voix,
mais s'il tarde,
il faut qu'il sache
comment se porter
dans l'Église.
Ce qui est important
pour nous,
c'est de considérer
que les plus grands
des mystères révélés
concernent directement
la création
d'un peuple,
concernent directement
l'Église,
les croyants.
L'intérêt des dieux
d'avoir fait
cette œuvre glorieuse,
c'est avant tout
de pointer envers
la suprématie
de sa gloire,
de sa beauté
par l'œuvre
qu'il a faite,
par sa condescendance,
par sa grâce,
par sa sagesse,
par sa puissance,
la manifestation
de son amour,
les mystères
d'Évangile.
Mais l'objectif
est de révéler
cette gloire
dans sa plénitude,
non seulement
dans sa révélation
plus belle
et plus écartante
lorsqu'il Christ
est incarné
et qu'il fait son œuvre,
mais par les effets
de ce que Christ
est venu de faire,
c'est-à-dire
les implications
pour la vie
de l'Église.
La capacité
de ses messages
de satisfaire
pleinement
des joies
les croyants
et par
la conviction
renforcée
des chrétiens
à propos
de ces faits,
provoquons-nous
une relation
expérimentale
avec la révélation
des dieux
et que cette piété
qui a pris possession
de nos pensées
les plus élevées
et de nos affections
les plus profondes
se manifeste
dans la manière
dont on va se porter
dans la vie.
Le but de l'Église,
la raison d'être l'Église
c'est de chanter
et de proclamer,
de déclarer,
de préserver
ses vérités.
Et je vous ai dit,
même si plusieurs
veulent suggérer
que la foi chrétienne
est dessautée
des mystères en mystère,
les mouvements
du Nouveau Testament
disent les contraires.
C'est un grand mystère,
le plus grand des mystères
qui a été révélé
d'une fois pour toutes
et c'est de méditer
dans la profondeur,
la largeur,
la hauteur
de la gloire
de ces événements
qui vont faire croître
notre piété.
Et la piété,
elle est décrite ici
en ayant ces trois aspects.
Une déclaration des fois
qui doit être faite
avec une conviction profonde,
croire profondément
dans chaque facette
de ces mystères.
Elle doit être
non seulement crue
avec ferme conviction
à point d'être vue
et perçue pour nous
comme si incontestable,
comme elle est présentée
dans cette déclaration,
incontestablement,
ces mystères
ont été révélés.
Donc l'un des objectifs
de l'apôtre Pauliste
dans ces passages,
c'est de démontrer
comment Dieu le Père,
Dieu le Fils,
ils les ont déclarés
à tous
que les Christs
étaient fils des dieux,
la manière dont
les Saint-Esprits
ont justifié les Christs
comme fils des dieux
avec puissance,
la manière dont
les anges eux-mêmes
ont attesté,
donc de manière visible,
historique,
publique,
c'est impossible
de contester au fait
que Dieu s'est fait chair.
Mais c'est surtout
pour nous les Chrétiens
qui allons donner
suite
à cette attestation
que nous devons
avant tout
être ceux
qui ont
les plus fermes convictions
à propos
de ces faits historiques
qui font
notre piété.
Mais cette confession,
elle doit être
proclamée.
Donc,
c'est ce que l'Église
doit faire,
professer publiquement,
continuer d'attester
publiquement
ces vérités.
Donc,
la relation entre
mes convictions
et la déclaration
publique
de ces convictions.
Mais elle doit être
déclarée en forme
des chants
car on voit
que ses crédos
est l'un des crédos
les plus anciens
de l'Église
mais il est aussi
un chant.
car ça démontre
les plaisirs
qu'on doit avoir.
un témoignage
pour plus apologétique
et intellectuel
qu'il soit
à propos de la vérité
n'a pas la même force
ou puissance
qu'un témoignage
rempli
des passions,
d'authenticité,
rempli
des joies.
Ils sont très faibles
témoins
des dieux
ceux qui sont toujours
dans la tristesse.
Comme dit Logan,
c'est une contradiction
la dépression
et les mots chrétiens
car ce sont
les vérités
qui doivent communiquer
une joie débordante.
C'est de déclarer
en forme de chant.
Vous comprenez ?
Et donc la piété
c'est la vie
des dieux en nous.
Dieu manifester
un chair
à travers nous
est l'objectif
de la porte-pôtre.
Et voilà pourquoi
ce texte nous sert
non seulement
pour Noël
mais il nous sert aussi
pour rétablir bien
nos buts
pour les nouvels
car il est lié
à ce qu'est
à l'église.
L'église
du Dieu vivant,
la maison des dieux,
colonne
et appui
de la vérité.
Défendre,
protéger,
proclamer
et laisser trouver.
Lorsque les personnes
rentrent dans la maison
des dieux,
nous qui sommes
les croyants,
qui composons
chacun de nous,
les pierres vivantes
habitées par l'esprit
et lorsque nous sommes
ensemble,
nous sommes en train
de déclarer publiquement
ces vérités.
Lorsque les personnes
rentrent ici,
ils doivent trouver
une communauté
qui est en train
d'être déclarée
avec ferme conviction
la vérité
en chantant,
avec joie.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
C'est ça la maison des dieux,
c'est ce qui nous sommes.
Malheureusement,
quand on arrive
à l'occasion
des nouvels ans,
à plusieurs reprises,
on essaye
d'anticiper
les mystères
qui viendront
de manière temporelle,
charnelle et humaine.
Et parfois,
nous développons même
une mentalité
à l'opposé du chrétien.
On anticipe plus
les mâles
qu'il est bien.
Et le plus important
pour nous,
pour plus que ce soit
légitime quelque part
d'avoir d'autres projets
subserviant à la mission
des dieux pour nous,
nous devrions être plus
concentrés sur les mystères
révélés
que les mystères
inconnus.
Car la certitude
que nous avons
et que nous devons avoir,
c'est que peu importe
ce qui viendra,
ça va contribuer
à la progression
de notre piété.
Tant mieux pour nous
nous concentrer surtout
sur des objectifs
sans,
pieux.
Et le but pour nous,
c'est nous demander
qui sommes-nous
et pas
qui vous voudriez être
en termes sociaux.
Qui sommes-nous ?
Et nous sommes avant tout
la maison des dieux,
colonne,
appui de la vérité,
l'église.
Habitation du dieu
qui se manifeste
à travers notre chair.
Nous sommes des petits Christ.
Et ça devrait être
notre objectif principal
pour 2025.
être chaque fois plus
de manière,
chaque fois plus intentionnelle,
plus similaire à Christ.
Que devons-nous faire ?
Nous devons faire
trois choses ici.
Croire avec une conviction
incontestable,
renforcer nos convictions
à propos des sévérités
surnaturelles
et historiques
à propos de notre foi,
croire avec ferme conviction,
confesser
ou déclarer publiquement
et chanter.
Donc,
quelles doivent être
nos résolutions
pour 2025 ?
Grandir
en connaissance,
en conviction,
grandir
en expérience
d'adoration
et grandir
dans la déclaration
et dans la manifestation
des dieux dans notre chair.
Santification
et partage de l'évangile.
Et comment pouvons-nous
les faire ?
Et voilà pourquoi
on est en train
de nous tarder
dans ces passages
car nous pouvons
grandir dans ces convictions
en nous plongeant
dans cette déclaration
inspirée
que l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de nous présenter.
Nous devons renouveler
de manière intellectuelle,
de manière expérimentale
et de manière pratique
la contemplation
de ces mystères.
À la mesure où l'Église
contemple
l'effet incontestable
de la manifestation
des dieux en chair,
l'Église
intensifie
ces convictions
approfondit
ces affections
et elle va déclarer
avec plus d'efficacité
et puissance
Dieu manifesté en chair.
Nous serons plus pieux,
nous serons plus efficaces
et nous allons porter
notre contribution
historique
pour continuer
d'attester
qui Dieu s'est manifesté en chair.
Et ce point important
car il est lié
au point
qu'on va traiter aujourd'hui.
Donc la réalité
c'est que si nous voulons
mieux comprendre
ce que nous sommes,
assumer notre identité
et faire ce que Dieu
veut faire à travers nous,
faire ce que nous devrions faire,
ce qui fait notre joie,
ce qui fait notre raison d'être,
nous devons
renouveler notre piété
par la contemplation
de ces déclarations
pour célébrer
ces grands mystères.
C'est important pour nous
de nous rappeler
que chaque facette
de ces mystères
tels qu'il nous est présenté
a pour but
non seulement
de nous conduire
à une ferme conviction
et une contemplation
glorieuse
de ces facettes,
mais
elles ont pour but aussi
démontrer
de quelle manière
Dieu
a attesté
et de manière incontestable
que Dieu
s'est fait chair.
Et donc,
afin de raviver
notre piété,
nous devons contempler,
déclarer,
célébrer
les six facettes
qui sont présentes ici.
Nous avons déjà considéré
trois.
La première,
c'est incontestable
que Dieu
se soit manifesté
en chair.
Et nous avons déjà
considéré comment
de manière incontestable
les pères
déclaraient
que l'Écrit
c'était les fils.
La manière incontestable
dont Jésus-Christ
incarnait les fils
s'autodéclarait
Dieu lui-même.
On a vu plusieurs passages
qui démontrent
des évidences
que Christ était Dieu
dans l'Ancien Testament,
dans les Nouveaux Testaments.
Et nous avons vu aussi
l'absolue
nécessité médiatrice
que l'Écrit soit
100% Dieu,
100% homme
pour pouvoir nous représenter
devant Dieu.
Sinon,
il n'y a pas de salut.
Ensuite,
on a considéré
la deuxième facette,
l'incontestable
révendication
du Saint-Esprit
à propos
de l'incarnation
messianique
du Fils des dieux.
C'est-à-dire,
les Saint-Esprits
des dieux,
pendant toutes les étapes
de l'incarnation
du Christ
et de son ministère
messianique,
les Saint-Esprits,
de manière très récourante,
explicite,
ouverte et publique,
a laissé des preuves
incontestables
qu'il était véritablement
le Fils des dieux.
Donc,
comme une colombe
lorsqu'il est baptisé,
la manière dont
le Saint-Esprit
va participer
à engendrer
les Christ
dans les ventes
des maris.
Pendant tous les mystères
du Christ,
pendant qu'il opère
des miracles,
pendant qu'il proclame
l'Évangile,
c'est par la puissance
de son esprit,
mais c'est surtout
en Romain 1,
verset 1 à 4,
que le Saint-Esprit
a rendu preuve
incontestable
que les Christ
étaient fils des dieux
car il n'a pas pu
être retenu
par la mort.
Il était le seul
100% saint
qui a souffert
à notre place,
mais il est ressuscité.
Donc là,
en Romain 1 à 4,
nous lisons
que l'Évangile
des dieux,
c'est l'Évangile
du Fils des dieux
qui est né
selon la postérité
de David,
mais il a été
déclaré
fils des dieux
avec puissance
selon l'esprit
de Saint-Esprit
par la résurrection.
et donc la résurrection
du Christ
ne peut jamais
être mise en question
de la part
d'un croyant.
Au contraire,
c'était l'une des manières
les plus évidentes
ou la plus importante
des manières
par lesquelles
le Saint-Esprit
a réclamé le Christ
comme fils des dieux
avec puissance.
C'est la preuve
qu'il est mort
véritablement sans péché
car il ne peut pas
être retenu par la mort
car les salaires
du péché
et la mort
et comme il n'avait pas péché,
il est mort pour nos péchés
mais il ne peut pas
rester dans la mort.
Et par la résurrection
publique évidente
qui a été apportée,
le Saint-Esprit
était en train de dire
voici les fils des dieux
avec puissance.
Donc que Dieu
soit manifesté en chair
était aussi
revendiqué par l'esprit.
La troisième chose
qu'on a vue
c'était les témoignages
des anges.
Donc remarquez bien
l'intérêt des dieux
à laisser clair
et malheureusement
inexcusable
à tous les êtres humains
dont leurs histoires
vont croiser
avec les évidences
de l'histoire du Christ.
Les plus on s'approche
de l'histoire du Christ
même de la fiabilité
des évangiles,
les plus on devient
responsable
à la manière
dont on va réagir
aux preuves incontestables
qui sont registrées.
Mais plus que ça,
comme nous le verrons
aujourd'hui,
l'Église,
elle reste aussi
un témoignage
incontestable
de la vivacité
de l'œuvre du Christ,
de la continuité
de l'œuvre du Christ
ressuscité.
Et les Saint-Esprit
travaillant à travers
l'Église
et parmi l'Église
déviant aussi
celui qui est constamment
en train de revendiquer
l'œuvre du Christ
chez les chrétiens
comme une œuvre incontestable.
Et donc nous sommes
de plus en plus
inexcusables,
de plus on s'approche
de cette révélation
glorieuse.
Mais de l'autre côté,
l'intérêt pour les croyants.
Car l'intérêt des dieux
c'est de renforcer
tellement
ces grands mystères
révélés de l'incarnation
du fils des dieux
afin que nous,
à chaque génération
et dans toutes les générations,
soyons ceux
qui croient
fermement,
fermement
dans la manifestation
des dieux en chair
en Jésus-Christ.
Et donc toutes ces couches
de confirmation
publiques
continuent d'avoir lieu
de manière spirituelle
au sein de l'Église.
Dieu continue.
Lorsqu'il s'est converti,
il dit
lorsqu'il a plus de Dieu
de révéler son fils en moi.
Lorsqu'il nous convertissons,
nous avons l'expérience
des dieux
qui réclament Christ
comme fils des dieux
pour chacun d'entre nous
qui sommes des vrais chrétiens.
Les Saint-Esprits
font l'œuvre aussi.
C'est lui
qui va attester
à nos esprits
qu'il est Christ
le fils des dieux
et qu'il nous sommes
en Christ,
fils des dieux.
Et même si on n'est pas
tous conscients
de la manière
dont les anges
sont en train
de témoigner
à propos du Christ
et de coopérer
avec notre conversion,
la Bible nous enseigne
que les anges
sont des témoins
fiables,
fidèles,
qui sont à service
de ceux qui croient.
Et donc,
le troisième
élément
qu'on a considéré
les dimanches derniers,
c'était
l'incontestable témoignage
des anges
à propos
de l'incarnation
messianique
du fils des dieux.
quel intérêt
des dieux
de faire
que ça soit
indubitable,
surtout pour les croyants,
tous les faits
qui composent,
toutes les facettes
qui composent
ces mystères.
Donc,
les anges
ont un grand intérêt,
sont un grand modèle
de ce que nous devons être
en tant qu'église
pour le monde.
Car les anges,
lorsqu'ils ont témoigné
de la naissance du Christ,
chaque étape
du ministère du Christ
et même sa glorification,
lorsqu'ils montent au ciel,
les anges,
à chaque fois,
sont en train
de déclarer
ces vérités
avec conviction,
ils sont en train
de servir
en tant qu'étoiles
et témoins,
ils ont vu ces choses,
ils ont de l'intérêt
pour ces choses
et ils doivent être
pour nous des modèles
car nous sommes
comme des anges
pour les mondes perdus.
Nous devons déclarer
avec conviction
comme ceux qui ont vu
avec les propres yeux
spirituels
ces réalités
et qui doivent les déclarer
comme les anges
pour les saluts
des perdus,
en chantant
avec la célébration
des anges.
Et aujourd'hui,
nous passons
à la prochaine facette
et celle qui concerne
les témoignages
de l'Église
car nous sommes aussi
une preuve incontestable
du fait
que Dieu s'est fait chair.
Donc, verset 16,
il nous dit
sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété
est grand,
c'est lui
qui a été manifesté
en chair
justifié par l'esprit
vue des anges
a été incontestablement
prêché aux gentils.
Et là,
nous sommes devant
un des éléments
les plus glorieux,
les plus mystérieux
qu'on puisse imaginer
à propos
de la révélation
des dieux
en chair.
Les mystères,
on peut comprendre
quelque part
l'aspect surnaturel
de ces mystères
quand on pense
par exemple
à Dieu
qui parle
du fait
qu'il crie
c'était fils des dieux
ou qu'il écrit
ce qu'un homme visible
réclame être Dieu lui-même
ou qu'il est
en train de se faire
ces êtres spirituels
puissent apparaître
de temps en temps
pour attester.
Et là,
l'expression mystère
semble plus appropriée.
Mais comment
il y a cette notion
des
il a été prêché
aux gentils
comme en étant
la révélation
d'un mystère glorieux.
Et c'est intéressant
de voir comment
ou avec quelle richesse
la parole de Dieu
nous montre
que la grandeur
de ces mystères
peut être constatée
par le fait
que la puissance
salvatrice
a été largement
étendue au monde
et qu'il était
à proclamer
avec assurance
envers les pires
des pécheurs.
Donc à la 3, 8
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que dès le départ
car rappelez-vous
les termes mystères
parlent des promesses
qui ont été faites
dans les temps anciens
et qui à partir
de la venue du Christ
ont été révélées,
éclatées
de manière incontestable,
visible, explicite.
Et nous ne pouvons
jamais oublier
malgré
tous les développements
préparatoires
du rôle
médiateur d'Israël
pour les saluts
de tous les peuples,
les peuples juifs
ont perdu
des vues
pendant
une bonne partie
de l'histoire
les faits
qu'ils n'étaient pas
les débuts de promesses
ni la fin de promesses.
Les rôles médiateurs
des juifs
ce n'était pas
qu'ils soient considérés
à toujours et pour toujours
comme les peuples
les plus importants
ou les peuples
les plus pieux
d'entre tous les peuples.
Il fallait que Christ
vienne à travers les juifs,
il fallait que cette nation
soit un peuple
répère
pour communiquer
des vérités spirituelles
à travers son rôle
temporel.
Mais la promesse
de l'évangile
à tous les peuples
ne commence pas
avec Israël.
Depuis la chute
de la descendance
de la fin
viendra un
qui va écraser
la tête du serpent.
Les messages
du salut
c'était pour l'humanité.
Et en Galate
on a pu mieux
comprendre aussi ces choses.
Mais c'est intéressant
car en Galate 3.8
l'apôtre Paul
va dire le suivant
et l'écriture
attention
prévoyant
que Dieu
justifierait
les païens
par la foi
avant
Isaac
avant Jacob
Israël
et les douze
Dieu
a dit
à Abraham
le peuple israël
n'était pas encore
fournit.
Dieu
justifierait
par la foi
les païens
à annoncer
c'est glorieux
à récit
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train
d'annoncer l'évangile.
C'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train
de proclamer
les mystères
du salut
de tous les peuples.
Donc ici il va dire
Dieu a annoncé
d'avance
la bonne nouvelle
à Abraham
en ces termes.
toutes les nations
seront bénies
dans toi.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
On ne peut pas perdre
de vue
de quelle manière ?
Attention
la proclamation
aux païens
aux gentils
est confirmée
comme un fait historique
qui atteste
l'accomplissement
de cette promesse
de ce mystère
de Dieu
qui a été révélé.
Si on pense
à Jonah par exemple
on peut comprendre
un peu
de la difficulté
humaine
naturelle
corrompue
qu'un juif
puisse
proclamer
l'évangile
aux perdus
aux gentils
car la conception
juive c'est
nous sommes
les privilégiés
les religieux
les plus pieux
entre toutes les nations
eux ils sont
les chiens.
Et donc c'est surprenant
à partir du moment
où les disciples
du Christ
commencent
à proclamer
l'évangile
à toutes les nations.
Romain 15
8 et 9
nous dit
j'ai dit
que Jésus Christ
a été
ministre
des circoncis
pour confirmer
les promesses
au Père
et que les païens
glorifient Dieu
pour sa miséricorde.
Selon qu'il a été écrit
c'est pourquoi
je célébrerai
parmi les païens
et je chanterai
à la gloire
de ton nom.
Donc ici c'est intéressant
Paul
qui présente
Jésus Christ
comme un ministre
des circoncis
afin d'accomplir
à travers
les ministères
des juifs
l'accomplissement
plan
de la rédemption
pour toutes les nations.
Et c'est beau
de voir aussi
qu'ici
les païens
glorifient Dieu
pour sa miséricorde
selon qu'il a été écrit
c'est pourquoi
je célébrerai
parmi les païens
et je chanterai
à la gloire
de ton nom.
Donc attention
ceux pour qui
les Christ
est venu
l'ont refusé
la majorité
une bonne portion
s'est convertie
la plupart des personnes
surtout au début
du livre d'actes
ce sont des juifs
convertis
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
même si la majorité
des juifs
est en train
de refuser
les Christ
comme Messie
de refuser
de reconnaître
qu'il est
le mystère révélé
c'est éclatant
de voir
de quelle manière
cet évangile
est en train
de s'étendre
parmi les païens
et les païens
sont en train
d'accomplir
attention
sont en train
d'accomplir
la raison d'être
une église
car ils sont en train
de croire
fermement
et ils sont en train
de célébrer
ils sont en train
de chanter
la gloire
et la miséricorde
des dieux
actes 3
25 et 26
vous êtes
les fils
des prophètes
et de l'alliance
que Dieu a faite
avec vos pères
en disant
à Abraham
et toutes les familles
de la terre
seront bénies
en ta postérité
c'est à vous d'abord
que Dieu
ayant suscité
son serviteur
l'a envoyé
pour vous bénir
en détournant
chacun
de vos méchantes actions
donc à vous d'abord
mais en rappel
que toutes les nations
devraient être bénies
et en acte 13
car ainsi
nous sommes ordonnés
par les seigneurs
j'ai t'établi
pour être
la lumière des nations
afin que tu sois
les salues
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
donc quelle est
notre résolution
c'est de comprendre
que la raison
pour laquelle
Dieu nous a choisis
ce n'est pas
pour nous enrichir
en 2025
ce n'est pas
pour nous guérir
de toute maladie
ce n'est pas
pour que notre carrière
professionnelle
soit développée
pour qu'on soit
plus célèbre
qu'on ait
moins de problèmes
dans la vie
Dieu dans sa grâce
peut nous concevoir
toutes ces choses
mais il nous a appelé
pour être
lumière des nations
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
un monde
qui est dans les ténèbres
aucune signification
plus élevée
pour nous
manifester la vie
des dieux
les personnes
en nous regardant
contemplent le dieux
qui déborde en nous
par la présence
de son esprit
et la proclamation
avec confiance
et joie
de la vérité
lumière
pour les nations
c'est important
car
c'est un texte
qui concerne
les païens
mais c'est un texte
qui est
un réproche aussi
aux juifs
et aux juifs chrétiens
ceux d'entre nous
qui peuvent développer
un air
de se sentir
plus important
qu'il est pire
des païens
les religieux
l'orgueux
religieux
qui pensent
que
l'obligation
des dieux
et l'intérêt
c'est à cause
de notre piété
religieuse
nous bénir plus
que les perdus
et qui sont en train
de vivre
plein de crises
dans la société
car ils ont appris
par certaines théologies
de prospérité
à développer
une vision
envers les perdus
comme si eux
ils étaient la tête
et les perdus
la queue
en attendant
que Dieu soit obligé
à satisfaire
toutes les déclarations
qu'ils font
dans leur prière
en mettant Dieu
contre les murs
par contre
ceux qui savent
qui sont les pires
des pécheurs
lorsqu'ils se convertissent
c'est comme
lorsque Dieu dit
à ses pharisiens
devant la prostituée
celle qui a été
les plus pardonnée
c'est celle
qui aime les plus
qui croit
avec plus de conviction
c'est celle
qui chante
avec plus de joie
c'est important
car les références
de Paul
lorsqu'il va mentionner
les termes mystères
il sera expliqué
dans la plupart des temps
avec la conception
de l'évangile
étendue
à toutes les nations
Ephésiens 3
en 6
c'est pourquoi
moi Paul
je suis les prisonniers
de Jésus Christ
pour vous
les païens
si du monde
vous avez entendu parler
de la dispensation
de la grâce
de Dieu
qui m'a été donné
pour vous
savoir que
les mystères
m'ont été révélés
comme je viens
de l'écrire
en peu de mots
en les lisant
vous pouvez comprendre
quelle est ma connaissance
du mystère
de Christ
mystère
qui n'a pas été porté
à la connaissance
des fils des hommes
dans les autres générations
comme il a été révélé
maintenant
à ses 100 apôtres
et prophètes
par l'esprit
et deux points
quel est ce mystère
les païens
sont co-héritiers
forment un même corps
et participant
de la promesse
en Jésus Christ
par l'évangile
dès le départ
la vraie descendance
d'Abraham
n'est pas celle
biologique
ethnique
c'est celle
de la foi
co-héritiers
sans rendre
des distinctions
ce ne sont pas
des cousins
ce sont des frères
si nous sommes
un Christ
toutes les nations
Ephésiens 2
14 à 16
car il est notre père
lui qui est de deux peuples
non afféquents
en renversant
les murs des séparations
l'inimitié
en abolissant
dans la chair
la loi
des commandements
contenus dans les ordonnances
afin de créer
en lui-même
des deux
un seul homme nouveau
en faisant la paix
et de réconcilier
avec Dieu
les uns et les autres
en un seul corps
par la croix
en tuant par elle
l'inimitié
entre les peuples
entre
cette mauvaise conception
qui semble suggérer
plusieurs races
il y a une seule race
humaine
c'est qu'il était
surtout
réduit
dans la compréhension
aux juifs
à nous
les peuples
choisis
et toutes
les autres nations
les pires des païens
vous êtes avec moi ?
les religions
idolâtres
archaïques
les cultures
avec
des dieux païens
qui semblent
sanctionner
et même promouvoir
la promiscuité
de ces nations
que même entre
Sodome et Gomorre
ou Ninive
certains soient sauvés
ça serait impossible
dans la conception
les juifs
ou contemplons la croix
les crises
qui sont en train
de mourir
il ne peut pas être
considéré par les juifs
comme les messies
mais
les responsables
de la crucifixion
ces centeniers
qu'on pourrait attendre
qu'il n'y ait
aucune chance
des conversions
ou les voleurs
à la croix
et on voit
cette déclaration
après la mort du Christ
véritablement
cet homme
était fils
des dieux
il y a la femme
d'un prédicateur
que nous connaissons
nous apprécions
énormément
qui partage
son témoignage
elle a vécu
comme
missionnaire
pendant toute sa vie
elle avait déjà
15 ans de mariage
avec ses grands prédicateurs
et un jour
ils sont dans une sortie
d'évangélisation
et ils essayent
de partager l'évangile
aux prostituées
et même si elle est là
dans une
activité
d'évangélisation
dans son cœur
elle se pose
plein de questions
et elle se sent
réprochée
par le Saint-Esprit
comme si
le Saint-Esprit
avait imprimé
dans sa conviction
cette conception
la seule différence
entre toi
et cette femme
est la taille
de sa joupe
elle partage
cette expérience
avec son mari
elle doute
de son salut
son mari
dit
basé sur ce
tu me partages
je ne peux pas
être sûr
de ta conversion
rentre dans ta chambre
je prends soin
des enfants
elle a passé la nuit
et par la grâce
des dieux
c'est là
où elle a vu
les signes
des conversions
elle a vu
plein de transformations
dans sa vie
s'il y a
quelque reste
des sensations
d'être plus important
à cause
de nos performances
religieuses
les pensées
qui
les perdus
sont
plus proches
ou moins proches
de la portée
de la grâce
salvatrice
des dieux
s'il y a encore
quelques restes
des distinctions
entre peuple
culture
race
comme si
ces choses
étaient au-delà
de la portée
des dieux
de nous unir
en Christ
nous n'avons pas
encore compris
ces mystères
n'ont pas encore
été révélé
comme il faut
dans nos cœurs
c'est fini
les murs
de séparation
le fait
que ces mystères
soient révélés
de manière
incontestable
c'est de voir
que cette petite
communauté
des chrétiens
des apôtres
avec cette communauté
à Jérusalem
avec un apôtre Paul
qui avant
était les plus
orgueilleux
possiblement
de sa génération
d'entre les pharisiens
sont en train
de sortir
pour proclamer
l'évangile
aux chiens
c'est de considérer
la possibilité
qu'un persécuteur
ouvert
des paillants
ou des sectes
qui étaient
l'apôtre Paul
déviant
les grands apôtres
pour les gentils
pour les paillants
vous comprenez ?
et c'est intéressant
car c'était
eux-mêmes
les apôtres
en suivant
l'exemple du Christ
qui vont sortir
pour proclamer
la vérité
à toutes les nations
donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans un premier moment
comme l'Écrit
lui-même l'a dit
commencer par Jérusalem
mais aller aux extrémités
de la terre
donc en Luc 24
et 47
Jésus dit
Ainsi il est écrit
qu'il est écrit
qu'il ressusciterait
des morts
les troisième jours
et que la répentance
et les pardons
des péchés
seraient prêchées
en son nom
à toutes les nations
à commencer
par Jérusalem
Matthieu 24
cette bonne nouvelle
du royaume
sera prêchée
dans les mondes entiers
pour servir
des témoignages
à toutes les nations
et alors
viendra la fin
Matthieu 28
8 avant
Jésus s'approcha
leur par là
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
dans les ciels
sur la terre
allez faites
les disciples
de toutes les nations
les baptisants
l'ont du Père
du Fils
et du Saint-Esprit
et leur enseigne
à observer
tous ces que je vous ai
prescrits
et voici
je suis avec vous
tous les jours
jusqu'à la fin du monde
donc imaginons
les contextes
la persécution
juive
contre les chrétiens
et la persécution
des empires romans
contre les chrétiens
un groupe
des disciples
qui avaient
la plupart d'entre eux
une base
très simple
des formations
pas beaucoup de ressources
sans
GPS
sans Google
sans Internet
sans beaucoup
d'instructions
pour se contextualiser
aux autres nations
sans bien connaître
quelle sera
la culture
de tous ces mondes
qui étaient tellement
fragmentés
avec tellement
des cultures différentes
sans se préoccuper
à se demander
mais comment
nous allons prêcher
l'évangile
à ces peuples-ci
ou à ces peuples-là
et qui reçoivent
la tâche
de prêcher
l'évangile
à toutes les nations
l'être humain
est le même
les problèmes
radicals
de l'homme
est le même
l'évangile
est un seul
les problèmes
n'est jamais
avec la sémence
ou les sémeurs
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
sur les salles
et sur la terre
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
moi si je dépendrais
des pensées
à l'estile des vies
de ces autres cultures
combien réfratères
ils sont à l'évangile
si ce sont
des cultures très païennes
avec des religions archaïques
ou ce sont des religions
très sceptiques
athées
si on se base
tout simplement
sur
la volonté corrompue
de l'être humain
qui ne veut pas croire
la lumière
est venue
dans les mondes
et les fils
des hommes
ont préféré
les ténèbres
vous comprenez
c'est pas la faute
de l'évidence
du Christ
manifesté en chair
l'incrédulité
de certains
donc ça ne peut
jamais se baser
sur notre capacité
de convaincre
de ramasser
les ressources nécessaires
sur notre capacité
d'apprendre
un langage
qui sera plus efficace
ça dépend
de nos convictions
de nos affections
de notre déclaration
de notre témoignage
de combien rempli
du Saint-Esprit
nous sommes
et combien fidèles
nous proclamons l'évangile
car Dieu
manifesté en chair
va se révéler
et l'un des exemples
qui atteste
le plus
c'est comme l'exemple
de Dave DeHume
qui dans une période
où les rationalistes
ne faisaient que grandir
et plusieurs églises
commençaient
à échouer
en essayant
de s'adapter
au rationalisme
intellectualistes
ne faisaient
que baisser
leur fréquence
et parmi toute
une génération
d'églises
qui sont en train
de mourir
il y a un ministère
dont tel
Whitfield
qui commence
à prêcher
dans les places publiques
10 000 personnes
30 000 personnes
viennent pour l'écouter
et d'entre ceux
qui venaient l'écouter
vient tel
Dave DeHume
un grand philosophe
sceptique de l'époque
et son assistant
lui demande
mais pourquoi
tu vas t'apprêter
pour aller entendre
cet homme
si tu ne crois pas
à ce qu'il dit
sa réponse
lui
il croit
dans une génération
des vérités relatives
modernisme
ou post-modernisme
mise en question
d'une vérité absolue
la vérité est
celui
qui se manifeste
en chair
proclamer la vérité
avec conviction
manifester
la vie des dieux
en nous
est la manière
par laquelle
les personnes
viendront à croire
c'est important
de renforcer
ces points
car des fois
on entend parler
que
les temps
ont tellement changé
que les choses
ne puissent pas marcher
comme avant
on oublie en fait
que la genèse
de l'église
se passe
dans un environnement
complètement
réfratère
humaine
pardon
à l'explosion
de la croissance
de l'église
donc
qu'est-ce qui fait
que ces ministères
soient
ou que ces mystères
pardon
soient révélés
de manière attestée
et indubitable
c'est surtout
ces points-ci
non seulement
les faits bibliques
que ces mystères
ont été révélés
comme je vous ai montré
la promesse
concernait toujours
toutes les nations
mais les faits
non seulement
qu'un message
est porté
par ceux
qui avaient
les plus
des préconceptions
vous vous rappelez
Jésus
partage à la femme
samaritaine
et les apôtres
sont en train
de se demander
pourquoi Jésus
est en train
de donner attention
à cette femme
qui est si corrompue
et les crises
qui partagent
l'évangile
à cette femme
donc remarquez
les apôtres
ils avaient aussi
ces préjudices
dans un premier moment
ce sont ces mêmes apôtres
qui sont en train
de prendre un message
qui naturellement
à contre-cœur
ils allaient apporter
aux païens
et qui sont en train
de prêcher
cet évangile
à toutes les nations
quand on contemple
l'histoire de l'église
nous allons voir
comment non seulement
on sait que Pierre
est connu comme celui
qui est le leader
de ministère
à Jérusalem
dans un premier moment
mais c'est lui aussi
qui devient
les plus grands évangélistes
implanteurs d'église
à Rome
ok
donc lui il fait
l'Asie mineure
Rome
martyrisé à Rome
Jacques
il va prendre
dans toute la région
de la Judée
de la Galilée
et il va aller
jusqu'en Espagne
Jean
il va partir
dans un premier moment
de Jérusalem
pour aller aussi
en Asie mineure
dans les régions
autour d'Éphèse
et il va finir
à l'île des Patmos
là où il va écrire
Apocalypse
quand on considère
André
il va partir
vers la Grèce
l'Asie mineure
la City
ensuite
il sera martyrisé
aussi
en Grèce
Philippe
il part vers l'Asie mineure
ensuite Hierapolis
Barthélémy
l'Arménie
l'Inde
la Mésopotamie
Matthieu
ou Lévi
la Palestine
l'Éthiopie
la partie
Thomas
en Perse
en Inde
Jacques
en Asie mineure
Edessa
Jude
Syrie
Mésopotamie
Arménie
Liban
Simon
les Élotes
va vers Judée
Asie mineure
Afrique du Nord
et Paul
comme on connait tous
il a fait presque
tous les mondes anciens
qui côtoyaient
cette région
Asie mineure
Éphèse
L'Istre
Derbe
Iconium
La Galatie
Grèce
Philippe
Thessalonique
Corante
Athènes
Éphèse
Rome
Illyricum
en Albanie
et il est mort
aussi
à Rome
Qu'est-ce qui fait
la capacité
de ces hommes
de proclamer
un évangile
inconnu
à toutes ces nations
païennes
naturellement
à contre-cœur
à des peuples
entre guillemets
qui ne méritaient pas
par leur piété
mais les pires
des peuples
qui ne méritaient
à la France
c'était ceux
qui ont reçu
tous les privilèges
et qui ont refusé
les Christs
et là
ils ont compris
cette vérité
ils ont partagé
cet évangile
non seulement
à contre-cœur
mais surtout
contrairement
aux circonstances
nous aurions pu
avec les humains
avoir tous les motifs
de découragement
pour partager l'évangile
mais nous
ne sommes pas là
en train de jouer
contre les forces
humaines
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
dans les ciels
et sur la terre
allez donc
et faites des disciples
peu importe
qu'elle soit
la résistance
non seulement
à contre-cœur
mais contre
la persécution
en termes des juifs
la persécution externe
de l'Empire romain
et là
je vous ai partagé
de quelle manière
ils sont partis
proclamer
mais nous savons aussi
qu'ils sont partis
proclamer
et leur histoire
a fini
pour la plupart
d'entre eux
de manière très
mauvaise
par les martyrs
et ils sont morts
en prêchant
quelqu'un a déjà dit
qu'une croyance
ou une foi
peut être attestée
comme véritable
par rapport
à la manière
dont on vit pour elle
vous êtes avec moi ?
mais encore plus fort
que ces témoignages
c'est lorsqu'on la considère
digne de notre propre morte
!
ça ne peut pas
être vrai
n'est pas
lorsque ces hommes
sont en train
de prêcher
ils sont en train
de tomber
en prêchant
ils sont en train
de refuser
l'opportunité
de sortir vivants
en réunis
en leur foi
comme Polycarpe
la première génération
après Pierre
on lui dit
il suffit
d'être dire
malheur
aux athées
dans la conception romaine
athée c'était
celui qui ne croyait pas
que César
était une sorte
des dieux
et il dit
je ne peux pas
renoncer
mon Seigneur
à 86 ans
je les sers
il ne m'a jamais manqué
il dit plus ou moins
comme ça
tu es en train
de perdre ton temps
aller chercher
les bêtes sauvages
les feux
il m'a brûlé
et comme dit
Tertullian
les sangs des martyrs
sont la sémence
de l'église
car depuis Étienne
l'évangile
proclamé
dans la puissance
de son esprit
est un évangile
qui est ce qui
proclame
avec une telle puissance
avec une telle conviction
qu'ils sont en train
de mourir
pour les prêcher
avec un amour
pour ceux
qui sont en train
de les tuer
vous voyez
les contrastes
entre les vrais évangiles
et l'évangile
des croisades
faits par des soi-disant
chrétiens
qui voulaient imposer
la foi chrétienne
ou d'autres religions
qui veulent
subjuger
d'autres nations
pourquoi c'est un mystère
révélé
car c'est comme Paul dit
si la vie dans ma chair
porte encore des fruits
pour les ministères
je préfère rester
dans ses corps
c'est la seule utilité
c'est l'utilité
la plus élevée
mais d'être avec Christ
est incomparablement mieux
c'est de cette manière
que l'évangile
nous est arrivé
c'est de cette manière
que l'évangile
continue d'avancer
dans des régions
très persécutées
et voilà pourquoi
nous devrions
et ça c'est vraiment
un rêve
pour l'église Bonneauvel
pour nos conférences
restaurer
la proclamation
fidèle
avec conviction
avec hardiesse
de manière héraldique
comme des témoins
pas comme des philosophes
pas avec cette notion
des politesses
des discours
car Christ
c'est lui qui a été
manifesté en chair
comme dit Paul
en deuxième Corinthien
chapitre 5
il va dire
si quelqu'un est en Christ
il est une nouvelle créature
les choses anciennes
sont passées
voici toutes choses
sont devenues nouvelles
et tout cela vient
de Dieu
qui nous a réconciliés
avec lui
par Jésus Christ
et qui nous a donné
les mystères
de la réconciliation
car Dieu
était en Christ
attention
réconciliant les mondes
avec lui-même
qui fait l'oeuvre
Dieu
en éliminant
les imputants
les offenses
et il a mis
il a mis en nous
les croyants
la parole
de la réconciliation
nous sommes donc
des ambassadeurs
pour Christ
comme si Dieu
exhortait par nous
nous vous en supplions
au nom de Christ
soyez réconciliés
avec Dieu
c'est lui qui n'a pas
connu les péchés
il a fait devenir péché
pour nous
afin que nous devions
en lui
la justice des dieux
comme nous sommes
des travailleurs
avec Dieu
nous sommes des travailleurs
nous vous exhortons
attention
aussi à ne pas
recevoir la grâce
de Dieu en vent
car il dit
au temps favorable
j'ai été exaucé
et au jour du salut
j'ai été sécour
voici maintenant
les temps favorables
les jours du salut
c'est comme ça
qu'on prêche l'évangile
avec conscience
que Dieu
exhorte
parmi nous
Dieu
se manifeste
en chair
à travers son église
lorsqu'on proclame
la vérité
avec conviction
lorsque nous cherchons
à mettre
l'intellecteur
nous devons
les transferts
d'informations
avec
une projection
qui semble
plus intéressée
à éduquer
l'intellect
des personnes
que d'être
un véhicule
des reproductions
d'interactions
entre Dieu
et les hommes
nous pouvons utiliser
ces autres méthodes
dans un format
étude biblique
par exemple
mais ne touchons pas
à la prédication
à l'évangélisation
remplie
du Saint-Esprit
à un moment donné
on échange beaucoup
avec nos amis
mais à un moment donné
il faut que cette personne
ait la sensation
que Dieu lui parle
qu'elle est devant Dieu
!
qu'on connaît
on était à leur place
on connaît bien
les excuses qu'on donne
la manière d'échanger
d'arguments
des discussions
de poser des questions
pour dévier
les sujets
mais à un moment donné
il faut dire
mon ami
j'étais dans ta position
Dieu connaît
ton cœur
comme dit Paul
un petit peu
décontextualisation
en Athènes
j'ai passé
j'ai observé
l'objet de vos cultes
il y avait
pour un Dieu inconnu
un hôtel
c'est précisément
ces deux-là
que j'annonce
ok
il commence avec
un pont de contact
un langage accessible
tout cela est important
mais comment il finit
sa prédication
on n'est pas
les relâchant
allégeant
Dieu a fixé un jour
il a fonté
un homme
Jésus-Christ
pour juger
les vivants
et les morts
répandez-vous
c'est aujourd'hui
les jours
de salut
et comme
le John disait
les sermons
très profonds
intellectuellement parlant
il disait
j'ai pas de problème
si lorsque je commence
à prêcher
les personnes
prennent des notes
il faut pas arrêter
là
ceux qui sont
en train de prendre
des notes
mais si
pendant tous les sermons
il a pas eu un moment
il a lâché son stylo
pour se montrer
clairement impacté
par les messages
la sensation
des dieux
qui me parlent
la prédication
n'a pas eu son effet
moi j'ai échoué
il disait
l'intérêt de la prédication
pas qui l'intérêt
mais on commence par
l'intérêt de la prédication
n'est pas
tout simplement
les transferts d'informations
ou par des voies humaines
ou rhétoriques
vous conduire
à changer de pensée
à calculer
par exemple
vos avantages
etc
c'est
de présenter Dieu
à l'interlocuteur
et de mettre
l'interlocuteur
devant Dieu
et c'est comme ça
que la prédication
fidèle de l'évangile
atteste
du fait
que Dieu
s'est manifesté en chair
parce que l'évangile
a été prêché
proclamé aux païens
regardez la manière
dont la Bible
présente
les prédications du Béli
donc la puissance
de la proclamation
de l'évangile
est un témoignage
que Dieu
utilise
pour manifester
sa vie
pour opérer
son salut
et donc
dans ces
nouvel an
ça doit être
notre résolution
de prier
pour les
renouvellements
de la centralité
de l'importance
de la prédication
dans nos pupitres
et dans nos vies
dans nos relations
être intentionnels
remplis
couvrir
des prières
pour que Dieu
se manifeste
à travers nous
lorsqu'on proclame
l'évangile
pour que cette
ardiesse
pour que
cette
onction
pour utiliser
le langage
biblique
puisse nous couvrir
pour que
lorsque les
personnes
nous entendent
partager l'évangile
leur coeur
brûle
pour que
lorsque
nous proclamons
l'évangile
les saintes
esprit
ouvrent
leur intelligence
pour comprendre
pour que
lorsqu'on
proclame
l'évangile
comme devant
la prédication
du Christ
à cause
de son esprit
la réaction
soit
il ne prêche
pas
comme les
scribes
et pharisiens
car il parle
avec autorité
l'autorité
n'est pas
de crier
dans un serment
l'autorité
n'est pas
de donner
l'impression
d'être
arrogant
ou orgueilleux
de parler
à l'autre
du haut
vers les bas
l'autorité
c'est cette
urgence
nous vous
en souplions
c'est les jours
du salut
ne jouez pas
avec vos âmes
cette conversation
elle semble
n'est pas
percer
les ciels
pour que
l'interaction
soit surnaturelle
nous vous en souplions
c'est Dieu
qui vous parle
c'est pas moi
moi je n'aurais pas
si tant d'intérêt
honnêtement
tout seul
pour
gagner un argument
pour avoir raison
mon seul intérêt
c'est les saluts
de ton âme
nous devons être
en église
résolue
dans nos poupitres
dans nos interactions
et dans l'intercession
dans les soutiens
dans les supports
dans l'envoi
prions pour que
Dieu puisse
les faire
pour que notre église
soit aussi un témoignage
dans notre génération
des proclamations
fidèles
de l'évangile
à travers
de nouvelles implantations
de nouvelles générations
des pasteurs
d'implanteurs
d'évangélistes
prions pour que
les églises
de cette région
la France
les fassent aussi
prions
pour tous ces ministères
qui nous côtoient
et qui font un travail
global aussi
d'évangélisation
prions pour l'église
persécutée
soyons engagés
car ça
c'est la manière
dont encore aujourd'hui
la manifestation
des dieux en chair
en Jésus Christ
sera perçue
et reconnue
comme un mystère
incontestable
vous voyez la liaison
entre un témoignage
puissant de l'évangile
et la manière
dont les personnes
viennent à la foi
pour la foi